[Musique]
les microsillons dernier cette phase qui
semble pas nécessairement très optimiste
elle nous vient de louis pasteur l'un
des pères fondateurs de la microbiologie
qui très tôt avait réalisé l'incroyable
capacité de prolifération de survie et
d'adaptation des bactéries peut-être la
meilleure illustration de cette capacité
qu'ont les bactéries à résister après
travers le temps et dans tous les
milieux et peut-être le mieux illustré
par la roue de l'agît pour vous avez ici
l'ensemble des espèces vivant sur la
planète avec leur géologie l'art
généalogie pardon évolutive et vous vous
trouvez bien sûr sur la droite
parmi les derniers arrivants dans cette
une petite branche l'homme puis bien sûr
si l'on remonte les autres mammifères
les oiseaux les reptiles bien avancer
encore les amphibiens les poissons
ensuite on va trouver des insectes les
crustacés
si on remonte à un ou deux milliards
d'années on pourra les premières plantes
mais ce qui est important ici c'est que
vous pouvez voir ses premiers organismes
vivants être apparue sur la planète sont
des bactéries ont trimé effectivement
défaut si les bactéries qui ont trois
milliards et demi d'années et ce sont
d'ailleurs ces bactéries précoce qui ont
permis l'oxygénation de l'atmosphère et
l'explosion de la vie telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui
donc si vous aimez l'oxygène vous aimez
les bactéries et ce qui est important
ici également c'est que non seulement
les bactéries étaient là en premier mais
vous pouvez voir qu'aujourd'hui elles
sont bien entendu encore parmi nous et
plus diverses et plus prospère que
jamais donc on sait aujourd'hui que l
ont colonisés ont à peu près tous les
environnements
elles sont présentes dans les eaux des
rivières des maires des lacs des océans
elles sont présentes dans les sources
acides comme alicia yellowstone
elles sont également présentes dans les
abysses des océans associé à ce qu'on
appelle les fumeurs noirs ou les
températures et les pressions sont
pourtant extrême il ya même des
bactéries qui vivent dans les nuages
des bactéries qui vivent dans les glaces
ancestrale du permafrost
ou lentement mais sûrement elles
survivent elles peuvent même proliférer
elles peuvent même se divise et malgré
des températures très basses et enfin on
trouve des bactéries sur toutes les
surfaces possibles et imaginables
même ici sur la surface des cailloux des
déserts arides où pourtant l'accès à
l'eau et est très limité elles ont
colonisé tous les environnements mais
elles ont également coloniser les
plantes et les animaux et un corps
humain votre corps humain par exemple
contient deux à dix fois plus de
bactéries que de cellules humaines
c'est chez un adulte ça représente
environ 5 kilos de bactéries et si on
regarde au niveau génétique alors ça
veut dire que vous êtes composé de 100
fois plus de gènes bactériens que deux
gènes humains
donc c'est ce qui fait de l'homme ce
qu'on appelle un hollow bio c'est à dire
une niche écologique résultant de
l'association entre un autre et une
multitude d'autres espèces vivantes
donc ces autres espèces vivantes ces
microbes en grande partie des bactéries
constituent ce que ce que l'on appelle
le microbiote et ce microbiote vit en
parfaite symbiose avec son hôte et il
réalise des fonctions importantes pour
la survie de l'autre comme par exemple
l'aide à la digestion
les bactéries peuvent synthétiser aussi
des molécules importantes comme les
vitamines mais ces microbes protège
surtout en collaboration avec notre
système immunitaire protège surtout
contre l'invasion par d'autres bactéries
qui elle ne pourrait pourrait ne plus
être dans une relation symbiotique
mais dans une relation pathogénique
c'est à dire dont la prolifération se
ferait au détriment de l'homme se ferait
en déclenchant des maladies donc c'est
le cas de des maladies bactériennes je
vous ai mis là quelques exemples de
maladies bactériennes bien connue comme
la tuberculose le choléra ou la peste
noire j'aurais bien sûr pu mettre
d'autres exemples la dysenterie la
salmonelle ou autre et bien sûr c'est
contre ces bactéries là qu'il nous faut
développer des traitements et des armes
efficaces
donc qu'est-ce qui explique le succès
des bactéries la réponse réside sans
doute en partie dans leur incroyable
capacité et vitesse de prolifération
donc vous avez ici une vidéo microscopie
on l'envoie à la bactérie escherichia
coli est une bactérie commune du du tube
digestif des mammifères qui fait
quelques quelques micromètres quelques
millionièmes de mètre et vous pouvez
voir qu elle se divise très rapidement
en 30 minutes nous avons une cellule qui
peut donner deux cellules donc pour
comparer par rapport au temps de
génération de l'homme qui est d'une
vingtaine d'années en ce laps de temps
la bactérie a le temps de faire trois
cent cinquante mille générations
donc si vous demandez à une calculette
même une bonne calculette scientifique
combien de bâtir une obtient après 350
mille générations vous allez obtenir
notre number c'est trop grand ça veut
pas être calculé en revanche pour mieux
comprendre ce chiffre cette vitesse en
16 heures c'est à dire environ 33
division une bactérie génère
l'équivalent de la population mondiale
c'est à dire environ 8 milliards de
bactéries donc non seulement elle
prolifère rapidement
elle arrive à des populations composées
d'un grand nombre de bactéries mais
elles ont également au sein de cette
population une variabilité génétique
c'est-à-dire qu'au cours des divisions
au cours des générations
elle accumule ce qu'on appelle des
mutations spontanées qui rendent par
exemple ici l'imaginons ces deux
bactéries sensiblement différente des
autres bactéries qui composent la
population est ce qui est important ici
c'est que ces petites différences
génétiques peuvent être accompagnés d'un
avantage sélectif
lorsqu'il ya ce qu'on appelle en
biologie un stress un changement de
l'environnement de température d'acidité
ou autre et ça c'est particulièrement
intéressant dans le cas qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui qui est le cas des
traitements antibiotiques
donc les antibiotiques je vous rappelle
ce sont des molécules qui sont dirigés
spécifiquement contre les bactéries et
qui empêche soit leur prolifération ou
qui directement peuple et les tuer tout
simplement
donc on peut imaginer que cette
population ici va être traitée par un
antibiotique et seuls les deux bactéries
qui auront acquis ces mutations
spontanées vont pouvoir survivre
non seulement elles peuvent survivre
mais elles ont maintenant tout le loisir
de se développer dans cette nouvelle
niche qui a été libéré où elles n'ont
plus de compétition et aboutir à une
population qui est entièrement
résistante donc celle à l'ambiguïté de
l'utilisation des antibiotiques qui est
d'un côté tu la majeure partie des
bactéries mais de l'autre vont aussi
favorisée
la sélection et la prolifération des
espèces qui sont qui sont elles
résistantes
donc ce que je vous ai expliqué la haut
niveau cellulaire rapidement on le voit
également à l'échelle de l'histoire
vous avez ici une frise chronologique ou
vous voyez en eau l'apparition des
différentes grandes classes
d'antibiotiques qui ont été qui ont été
découverts ou créés par l'homme jeudi
découverte parce que les antibiotiques
sont avant tout des armes que les
microbes eux mêmes utilisent pour
empêcher la prolifération des bactéries
avec lesquels sont en compétition et
d'autres antibiotiques une minorité ont
été pour le coup vraiment créé par par
l'homme mais ce qui est important ici
c'est que vous pouvez voir avec les
couleurs correspondante qu'à chaque fois
qu'un nouvel antibiotique est introduit
en thérapies humaines
alors peu de temps après quelques années
parfois quelques mois on voit
l'apparition de résistances de bactéries
qui résistent à ces traitements
il ya ici pas une seule exception on
peut regarder plus rapidement le le
cadet carbapénèmes ici aux etats unis
les infections avec cette bactérie qu'on
appelle klebsiella pneumoniae qui
étaient résistantes aux carbapénèmes
étaient une minorité au début des années
2000 et vous pouvez voir que dix ans
après ces infections résistantes aux
carbapénèmes sont devenus la majorité et
en l'absence de capacité de traiter ces
infections alors bien sûr on cesser ces
infections sont associés avec une forte
mortalité
ce n'est pas un problème nord-américain
bien entendu vous avez ici
l'équivalent la propagation des
résistances aux carbapénèmes en europe
et vous voyez que d'année en année bien
sûr la situation et la propagation de
ces résistances et de plus en plus
inquiétante
donc à l'échelle mondiale on peut même
faire une prédiction
si on suit cette tendance et ce fameux
rapport
o'neill indique que en 2050 si la même
tendance est suivi alors il y aura plus
de morts dus aux bactéries résistantes
que de morts dus au cancer s'agit donc
bien d'un problème urgent et d'un
problème mondial et ce problème de
résistance et de lutte contre les
résistants sont biologie est souvent
assimilée à la théorie de la reine rouge
inspiré du livre alice au pays des
merveilles de lewis carroll ou la reine
rouge disait alice
ici tu vois on est obligé de courir tant
qu'on peut pour rester à la même place
et ça en biologie ça fait référence au
concept selon lesquelles l'évolution
permanente d'une espèce est nécessaire
pour que cette espèce puisse maintenir
son habilité à faire face à l'évolution
des espèces avec lesquels elle cohabite
avec lesquels elle co et évolue et on
pourrait même ajouter dans un sens avec
l'environnement également qui change
donc l'exemple trivial et celui du lapin
qui pour éviter son prédateur le renard
doit améliorer sa défense
et ça il peut le faire par un gain de
vitesse ce gain de vitesse va appliquer
sur la population de renards une
pression de sélection naturelle qui va
nous laisser survivre que les renards
qui pourront se nourrir qui eux mêmes
auront gagné plus de vitesse appliquant
à nouveau la pression de sélection sur
les lapins à nouveau sur les renards et
c'est donc dans ce cas là au sens propre
comme au sens figuré
ces deux espèces doivent courir tant
qu'elles peuvent pour rester à la même
place
c'est à dire pour éviter l'extinction et
survivre donc je vous ai dit comment les
bactéries survivent aux antibiotiques et
pour elle bien sûr il ne s'agit pas de
courir plus vite mais bien d'acquérir
ces résistances elles le font par le
mécanisme de mutations spontanées que je
vous expliquais mais ce que je ne vous
ai pas dit c'est que les bactéries ont
un autre super pouvoirs qui est de
pouvoir transférer directement la
résistance d'une bactérie à une autre
bactérie voisine qui peut d'ailleurs
être d'une espèce différente et par ce
mécanisme
la bactérie qui était initialement
sensible et tu as bhl par l'antibiotique
devient elle-même résistante
donc ça ça se fait par un mécanisme qui
s'appelle la conjugaison bactérienne et
au cours de ce mécanisme une bactérie
qu'on appelle donneuse qui est
résistante va pouvoir directement
transféré son information génétique à la
bactérie receveuse qui elle va utiliser
cette information génétique et les
informations de résistance qu'elle
comporte pour développer et devenir
elle-même résistante et ceci se fait par
simple contact entre les bactéries donc
au laboratoire ici au msb à l'université
lyon on s'est intéressé à ce mécanisme
transfert de résistance par conjugaison
bactérienne
et on a essayé de développer un système
expérimental pour visualiser ce
mécanisme en direct sous le microscope
donc vous allez voir ici un autre film
de microscopie où on a mélangé des
bactéries donc donneuse de résistante
qui apparaissent en verre et des
bactéries receveuse qui sont
initialement sensible à l'antibiotique
est ce que vous pouvez voir c'est que
les bactéries ici en rouge attire
d'abord l'adn ça ça vous ai montré par
l'apparition d'un point rouge dans ces
bactéries est que ces bactéries qui ont
acquis l'adn et qui ont un point rouge
deviennent elles-mêmes verte indiquant
qu'elles sont devenues aussi résistante
que les cellules donneuse initialement
et l'échelle de temps ici vous permet
d'apprécier que non seulement ce
mécanisme efficace dans la population
mais il est également très rapide en
moins de deux heures une bactérie
sensible devient résistante aux
antibiotiques
et ça ça a été une surprise mais quelque
part ça explique pourquoi la conjugaison
bactérienne et le transfert d'adr est un
acteur tellement important de la
propagation des résistances dans le
monde bactérien
il ya donc bien une course entre les
bactéries l'humanité sous l'arbitrage de
la reine rouge
les bactéries comme je voulais expliquer
ont pour elles cette capacité
d'adaptation génétique cette capacité de
mutation de transfert de résistance et
l'homme qui lui n'a pas ce luxe du temps
de génération rapide peu ceci dit
utiliser son intelligence pour
développer de nouvelles armes à mettre
en face de ces bactéries et vous pouvez
voir que cet effort de recherche a été
très intense jusque dans les années 70
et puis suite à sa pension qu'on avait
assez d'armes efficace contre les
bactéries
l'homme a arrêté de courir relativement
et c'est en partie ce qui explique
aujourd'hui l'apparition de deux
nouvelles infections qui sont
résistantes à tous les traitements
antibiotiques donc bien entendu la
communauté internationale est
parfaitement consciente de ce problème
est bien décidée à suivre le conseil que
la reine rouge prodigués à l'iss quand
elle disait si on veut aller ailleurs il
faut courir au moins deux fois plus vite
courir deux fois plus et ça veut dire
renforcer l'effort de recherche
recherche fondamentale pour mieux
comprendre comment ces bactéries
développent et ce transfert se
transmettent les résistants mais
également aux recherches plus appliqués
pour développer soit de nouveaux
antibiotiques fois de nouvelles
approches antimicrobienne et que c'est à
ce prix on pourra aller ailleurs c'est à
dire vers un meilleur contrôle des
résistances vers une meilleure santé
humaine vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]